thank you pax um and thank you everybody
for joining us today
very excited to have everyone and we
want to spend the next hour talking a
little bit about
what product management is um how you
potentially break into the field and
maybe going into some of the the
interview questions that you might
commonly see
so let me start off by sharing a little
bit about my background
i did my undergrad and my graduate
degrees both at stanford
and ended up in product management a
couple of years after i graduated
i'd say my first real product management
job was running product management for
the words with friends studio and all
the other with friends games for a
handful of years
i was a director of product in a company
called zynga
after zynga i moved to dropbox and ran
their business product for a couple of
years on the product management side
moved from dropbox to gusto um and then
from gusto to pilot where i'm now the vp
of product management
running the product management team and
the product design team
so we spent a little bit over 11 years
in product management leadership
at a handful of different silicon valley
startups and i'm very excited to share
some of the things that i have learned
with you today
um we will skip jc's biography
but jc has also had spent most of her
career in product management silicon
valley
working at companies like dropbox airbnb
wework and it's now the vpf product
at a startup called webflow so we wanted
to start out today
with a brick a brief overview of what is
pm and
the reason we find this pretty helpful
is one of the most common questions that
we
get from people either looking to break
into the field or people who have worked
with product managers
is i don't really totally understand
what this role is
it seems that it's a little bit
different with everybody i ask can you
give me a very brief overview of what it
actually means to be a product manager
and i think there's a really interesting
insight in that conversation
the pm job is definitely different in
every company it's different in every
company that we've ever worked at it's
different between hardware and software
companies it's different in silicon
valley non-silicon valley
but there's a lot of variants in this
role in a way that you would not
normally see for a traditional job title
um but after spending some time in the
field one of the things that
that we've concluded is there are
definitely some principles that stay the
same
across all the different product
management jobs so we want to start off
today by telling you a little bit about
what we think those principles are
and the commonalities between the roles
and then move on into some other topics
so let's start off first with the core
principles that we've seen be really
consistent across
product management um some of you may be
familiar with uh
this slide it's a fairly common picture
for representing how we think about
product management
um and what it tries to capture is
product managers released at the
intersection of a handful of different
fields
on the one hand you were often the
person representing the business
interest whether it's on a future basis
or a team basis
a big part of your responsibility is to
say how is what we're doing makes sense
for the business
you also represent the technology side
of things sort of get into requirements
for product managers and technical
backgrounds
in a minute but one of the other pieces
you have to do as a product manager
consistently is say
uh we represent the voice of technology
we're trying to build something new
we're trying to build something that has
never been done before
is this possible is it feasible or is it
viable
and on the last side one of the other
really core
characteristics of a product manager is
you're responsible for
ux and ux in the broadest sense of the
word it's actually thinking from a
customer perspective
and then a lot of research and
development organizations your
responsibility is to be the primary
voice of the customer
inside the building you might have teams
like support or sales that are talking
to customers at different points in the
product life cycle
but really your job is to represent the
customer when you're doing research and
development
this is one thing that we've definitely
seen be common across industries across
companies
and even sizes of company
another thing that we've seen be a very
strong commonality here
is is what we call the ceo versus the
janitor and
some of you may have heard the phrase
the product manager is the ceo of the
product
that part is definitely true what you
may not have heard is the product
manager is also the janitor of the
product
what we mean by that is we're both
responsible for things like
high level strategic vision and strategy
setting for
a product or for a set of features but
you're also responsible for all the
little things that fall through the
cracks
whether it's figuring out uh the latest
set of bugs and doing the prioritization
process
then whether it's helping write text or
copy whether it's freaking out what
color some things might
be your responsibility is to make sure
this thing
work so it's pretty unique from a role
perspective where
you're both doing high level work and
low level work at the same time
you really have a high dynamic range
which is pretty unique for a lot of
roles in
industry
the third thing that we we've seen um
sort of is a as a reframing of the the
ceo
janitor piece that i found helpful um
and it's all about big picture to bugs
and one of the things that was really
interesting for me
when i started my product management
career was in the morning i might have a
presentation to
the executive team the company and in
the afternoon i'm going through
500 buck reports that have been
submitted by customers and
i mentioned this on the last slide but
one of the things that i think has been
really powerful about the role
and a really good training ground for
eventually becoming an executive is
you're forced to figure out how to
grapple with things both at a high level
and at the low level simultaneously at
the same time
there's not a lot of rules where this is
true most roles are sort of operating at
one level of altitude pretty
consistently
one of the unique things we've seen
about product management and one of the
reasons why
we're obviously such big fans especially
early in mid-career
is you get exposure to a lot of things
that you would not normally get exposure
to otherwise
and it spans the full range all the way
from company strategy to
literally what should the sentence be
one of the other things we see is a very
common pattern in product management is
this concept of intra team and inter
team communication
and this one is very much a function of
company size but
as companies get larger or as
organizations get larger
one of the persistent challenges they
have is clear communication between
different parts of the organization
so that everybody is moving in the same
direction um
and we i took a quick look at some of
the companies uh list for people who are
attending some of you work at companies
that are tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands
or even potentially millions of people
and one of the very persistent
challenges and organizations of that
size
is how to the left hand knows what the
right hand is doing how you make sure
that the teams are coordinated and
communicating
so a really key component of the product
management job
especially as organizations get larger
is to be responsible for communication
and communication for us really breaks
down into two different buckets
one bucket about communication within
your team so both defending your team
from
uh changes that can happen outside of it
but also making sure that your team has
the context that it needs to do good
work
and there's the inter team communication
so how do you prevent two different
teams from accidentally working on the
same thing or
if another team has a dependency on your
team how can you keep them updated on
what you're doing
as companies get large the product
management job ends up being
very heavily this for friends who work
at larger organizations they might spend
in excess of 75
of their time in product management
during this inter and intro team
communication
this is very much a core role of the
product management
function and i would think of this as
scaling usually as organizations or
companies get larger
the next thing we wanted to talk about
is influence without authority
and this is another place for some of
you may be familiar
the product manager it might be the ceo
of the product but
usually in a reporting structure or in a
chain of command hierarchy nobody in the
engineering org reports to you
this does have a pretty interesting
dynamic it sets up a dynamic where part
of your responsibility is to be a leader
from a communication and from a strategy
perspective
but you may not have day-to-day line
decision-making power over the work that
somebody actually does
and the structure's set up this way on
purpose it is a feature not a bug
um the reason it's set up this way on
purpose is it forces you to go
to meet this higher bar of saying of
convincing people that
uh your strategy or your features or
your documents
are really correct and whereas in a
reporting structure somebody might just
have to listen to what you say
in this scenario it means you really
have a high bar for making sure that
you have defended your arguments and you
well reasoned through the set of things
that you're proposing
so influence about authority is
definitely a set of skills that you will
pick up
um there's sort of a whole toolbox that
we see product managers build for
becoming really good at this
over a series of years and if people are
interested we can talk more about this
in the q a section
two more topics that we really see as
common for the product management role
across
all the organizations that we've ever
seen one of them is knowing your user
um and this is really the classic uh
function of product management inside an
organization um the origins of product
management actually specifically to
bring users into the research and
development process
and we've sort of inherited that through
a long and distinguished lineage of
different organizations
but one of the absolutely core primary
jobs of a product manager at every
single organization
is to spend a lot of time talking to
users a lot of time talking to customers
and to deeply understand the set of
things that they need and if you can't
do that
all the other things are going to fall
apart because you will not build
something that people want or something
that people need
or something that meets the requirements
that have been set up
we spend a lot of time talking to
customers to really try and make sure
that we have very accurate mental models
of the set of things that they care
about
the last thing that we really see as a
commonality across a lot of the product
management
roles is what we call bringing the
donuts and this comes from a ken norton
blog post
who is a product manager at google for a
number of years
and the concept this really embodies is
you are both a leader of your team but
you need to be a motivator of your team
as well
and it's not really sufficient to lead
from the back
you need to lead from the front you need
to lead by example and
uh we say bringing the donuts because
it's representative of
sort of keeping team morale or keeping
team spirits high even when things are
difficult or even though things are
tough
even though you are not necessarily in
charge from a reporting structure
perspective a lot of the time you are
the anchor of the team or the spiritual
leader of the team
and your job is to make sure that
everyone is happy healthy and productive
and knows what they're working on and
why they're working on it
and if you're not able to be an
effective motivator and leader of people
it'll be very difficult for you to be
successful in the role
so those are the topics that we really
see as the the common principles that
exist
across product management we
differentiate between principles and
responsibilities
um the responsibilities are really what
your job is
versus a set of things you need to think
about and on responsibilities
perspective
we begin seeing four really common
patterns that exist across
product management agnostic of industry
agnostical company size
agnostic of all the other dimensions and
the first one that we spend a lot of
time talking about especially with more
senior product managers
is this notion of setting a vision and
this is something that you do uh
progressively more of as you get more
senior in your career
but a big part of the product
organization's purpose
is to have a vision and a strategy for
where the company is going from a
product perspective
what do we mean when we say vision and
strategy well i mean we say vision and
strategy is
uh there's a set of objectives that the
company might want to achieve
or the organization wants to achieve and
a part of your job is to figure out how
to get from where you are today
to where you want to be and really good
product managers do this
by setting goals instead of by setting
paths um
and what i mean by that is instead of
telling people you know do this thing
and do this thing and then do this thing
you'll say today we are here and we want
to be here
and you can harness the collective
intelligence to the organization to get
from
point a to point b it's a lot about
setting pushing decision making to the
people who have context
but if you can't set a clear goal for
your organization and then let people
apply their intelligence to figure out
how to achieve that goal you will have
an organization that is running in a
number of different directions
concurrently and it's very difficult for
them to accomplish anything
so this is really instrumental again is
it anything you do
more of as you progress through your
product management career but setting a
clear vision and a clear set of goals
for an organization
is an absolute must for any product
manager
the second thing that we really see is a
common characteristic common
responsibility across
organizations and companies is managing
a portfolio
and almost no product managers work on
only one thing
for those of you who have either worked
with product managers or have some
experience in the field
um you're probably not in your heads yes
when we bring this up
product managers seem to have uh their
fingers on a lot of different products
concurrently
and your job is to manage your portfolio
of things and the reason your job is to
manage the portfolio of things is
it's very difficult to accomplish a
complex a complex set of goals by doing
only one thing
so product managers need a very broad
set of skills
you manage literal portfolios of
projects from an r d perspective
but you might be doing a little bit of
business development or a little bit of
marketing or a little bit of sales or a
little bit of pr
um you need to know enough in a bunch of
different fields to be a bit dangerous
and this portfolio management piece is a
really sort of follows from the last
concept of
trying to achieve a goal you have to
have a robust set of skills to let you
do many things concurrently and then you
must make sure that all the individual
projects ladder up to more than some of
the parts
and that's really what portfolio
management about um this ties into road
mapping which is another concept that
some people the honest may be familiar
with
and we can spend some time on later if
people are curious but a roadmap is
basically your plan for managing a
portfolio of things and it's very much
one of the core tools of a product
manager
the third responsibility that again is
uh very universal across
all organizations is you have to
actually get stuff done and
you can have the best laid plans in the
world you can have the best roadmap in
the world you can be an excellent
communicator
but if you and your team are unable to
actually get things done
none of that really matters and a big
part of your job is to bring things into
existence that were not previously in
existence
it is a challenging execution problem
project management is a subset
of project management product managers
tend to do
some project management but also a bunch
of other things
but is it very much a core skill for
getting things done and again the
the core thesis here is if you're not
able to actually build stuff
and turn something into reality the best
laid plans don't matter
at all unless you can deliver it to the
world and to your customers
the the last part of the product manager
responsibility set
um is actually where we spend a lot of
our time and
it's called the product life cycle and
the product life cycle is
an industry and agnostic method of
taking
an individual idea from start to finish
and this is very much what we view as
the heart of the product management
discipline
you might have heard or seen product
managers who work on features who work
on products whether they're new whether
existing
a core responsibility and skill is to
take
a single idea and a single problem and
take it all the way from
idea to exist in the world and we have a
framework that uh joyanna and i have
developed over a number of years
that we think expressed this fairly well
in an industry agnostic sense
the framework involves things like
trying to figure out what problem you're
solving
why it's actually important it involves
figuring out how to design elegant
solutions to those problems
it involves an execution piece around
actually building things to get stuff
done
and also shipping piece that has go to
market components and pr components and
it recognizes that building is not
enough people will not come you need to
figure out how to get your product into
the hands of customers
involves a measurement component so that
you can really close the loop on your
hypotheses and figure out
did you accomplish what you wanted to
accomplish then the whole thing is
iterated
um sort of a variant of the scientific
method for those of you who are familiar
with that as well
but this is very much where we spend a
lot of our time coaching and training
your product managers
uh i think pax may mention this at the
end but we teach an entire online class
on just the product lifecycle concept
for those of you who are interested um
some opportunities to learn more
in the comments but this is very much a
core skill for product managers and
especially new product managers in their
career and it's something we spend a lot
of time
uh teaching people
so let's transition topics for a minute
um we spent the last
uh 15 20 minutes talking about what
product management is um
how is it consistent across companies uh
housing system across
organizations what do we really do as
the core responsibilities and the core
set of principles
let's transition a little bit to talking
about uh pm careers and i know there's a
lot of interest in this
from some of the comments and from some
of the the polls that we saw
but it sounds like many people in the
audience are either interested in
uh if you're already a pm how you
advance in your career if you're not a
pm how do you break into the field
or if you work with a lot of pms or
think it's an important set of skills
how do you have a better notion of what
is actually required to be good at this
for your day-to-day job um and
on the becoming at pm side one of the
the really tricky problems that some of
you may have confronted is
by far the most likely way to get a
product management job is to already
have another product management job
this generates an obvious next question
uh if it's a chicken and an egg problem
how can you go about breaking into the
field if that's something that you're
excited about
and i think there's really three common
paths that i've seen from working with
hundreds of product managers in my
career these are not the only paths
but i would say the paths make up
probably somewhere between 75
and 80 percent of the product managers
that i've worked with so i want to share
some of those paths with you and then
again if people are interested we can
spend some more time in q a
talking about uh different options so
the first path uh looks like a
structured training program and
uh there are a number of organizations
um google being one of the more
prominent ones
that have some concepts of an apm or
associate product manager program
these programs are often rotational
they're often something like a two-year
program
a number of companies in silicon valley
like google dropbox
facebook linkedin as a bunch of others
have
some analogous set of programs and they
recruit
people either out of undergrad out of
graduate school
out of business school or out of a
number of different places and they
basically put them through a
multi-year structured program to teach
them how to be a product manager
and this has some really nice pros and
cons one of the huge pros of something
like this is
an organization will invest a lot of
time and a lot of resources and training
you how to be good at this job
um the con of this is the the variance
on this is pretty low
there isn't really a world where you
come out of this two years in and you're
running
a very large organization or some very
complex product
this is a path that we very much
recommend for people who feel like they
learn best from instruction
where you'll get a lot of teaching a lot
of hands-on training
um and a lot of uh like good skill
development with pretty strong
safety in it uh if you're willing to to
roll the dice a bit and and are willing
to dial up some variants there's some
other interesting paths
um that i'd say are less structured but
can often or sometimes result in
higher ranges of outcomes
so the second path that we see is to
start
something and i use founder in the
broadest sense the word here it doesn't
necessarily need to meet
founder in the silicon valley classic
sense of i started a business i raised a
bunch of venture capital
um it can mean almost anybody who
started to run a small business
or a growing business so whether it's a
general manager
whether it's a small business owner
whether it's a literal venture-backed
startup founder
one of the things that's common across
all of those types of people is
you've had to do a little bit of
everything to know enough about
sales about marketing about
organizational structures about people
management about building something
people want
that some of those skills translate very
well into product management
this is a bit of a circuitous path so if
if your goal is to become a product
manager
i don't know that i would recommend that
you go start a company in order to
become a product manager
but um in a lot of the acquisitions that
i've seen or a lot of the hiring that
i've seen
i would guess that something somewhere
between like 15 and 25
of the product managers that i've worked
with ultimately came into product
management after
starting their own business in some way
so it may not have been their path from
the beginning but
there's a lot of overlap between project
management and founder
and it's a place that a non-trivial
number of people end up breaking into
the field this way
the last opportunity is is pretty broad
and it's just a category i'll call
getting lucky
um and getting lucky really means that
somebody gives you a break
and uh they make a bet on you and it's
kind of hard to have
a strategy that we suggest around this
um
really this is about a person willing to
go out of their way to say
i've worked with you i'm willing to put
some of my credibility on the line and
really back you here
um but i'll mention two things that i've
seen be
the highest probability paths in order
for people getting lucky
if you go back to some of the product
management responsibilities
that we talked about a few minutes ago i
think there are really
two key areas where you can develop
product management skills
in jobs that don't look like product
management one of them is talking to
customers and the other one is this
notion of
general management on the talking to
customer side of things two
organizations that i probably see most
often
end up breaking into product management
are some notion of
customer support or customer success and
some
uh and some people in sales and the
reason that both of those things are
true
is both of those organizations just
spend a lot of time talking to customers
and if you talk to enough customers
you'll have a really good sense of what
your customers care about
really accurate mental models of your
customers and that is such a core
part of the product manager job that if
you're able to bring a strong enough
representation of your customers
the an organization is sometimes willing
to teach you the rest of the pieces
around
uh prioritization road maps project
management et cetera
so i'd say one place where i've seen
more people
get lucky at breaking into the field is
by spending time in some role where they
talk a lot to customers
the other one is kind of similar to the
founder path that we talked about
and it's someone who has general
management experience in some way so
this can sometimes come in the form of
business development it can sometimes
come in the form of a literal general
manager of a function
but it means that you've spent time
building a lot of the skills like
managing a portfolio of projects
managing people
managing complex requirements uh you
probably have a pretty good financial
understanding and a pretty good business
understanding
so that's another place where you sort
of bring a different set of skills and
the bet they're making is well we can
teach you to talk to customers
so again right these are not the only
paths um i would say these are probably
the most common paths that i see
and if people are interested we can
spend a little bit more time on them
towards the end of the session
so what do people look for we talked
about some of the paths but really
what do people look for and what do we
look for when we're hiring people who
don't have a product management
background
a lot of these are probably unsurprising
a big part of the product management
role is figuring out how to be
intellectually honest about what you
know and what you don't know
so some combination of curiosity and
intelligence is particularly important
um curiosity because it's usually not a
great strategy to think that
you know what people want you need to
spend a lot of time talking to people
and if you're not genuinely curious it's
hard to fake that
um analytical ability and i'd say just
precision of thinking
ends up being very important as well
you'll be formulating a lot of complex
arguments
uh sort of complex theses and if you're
not precise and clear in your
communication your thinking style
it'll be difficult to do that well we
talked about domain expertise a bit
whether it's domain expertise on a
customer whether it's domain expertise
on
management really making sure that you
bring sort of an anchor set of skills
and one of the
things we talked about is important and
the last is is hard to
put a finger on but it's a bit about
potential um
it's really someone an organization
going out of their way and saying
we are excited and willing to make
so i want to transition a bit to talk
about some some common pm interview
questions i know this is one of the
things we mentioned
um in the the summary um and
got a lot of positive feedback about uh
most product manager interview questions
come from a relatively small set of
topics
um and there definitely are exceptions
to this but if you're looking for
a a product manager role say at any
technology company you're you're very
likely to get
some set of these questions and the
exact questions themselves may differ a
bit
exactly what the interviewer is looking
for might differ a bit but i
very much think of these as a pretty
common foundational set of topics
um and then there's lots of resources
that you can dig into if you want more
information on the topics
uh the first one which may be uh the
most obvious is some notion of product
intuition
and what we mean about product intuition
is the interviewer will try and figure
out do we feel like you have a good way
of understanding how
products actually work and how they
could be better so very common sense of
questions that we see here are things
like
um tell me about your favorite product
okay now let's assume that you're in
charge of it
how would you make it better what would
you do um that's probably
that or some variant of it is the most
common one that i see um
we see other things like uh you're given
a set of requirements you have to design
a product
so it might be something like uh how do
we design
uh how do we design a kitchen for
someone who only has the use
on hand or how do we make sure that
as we take product a and sort of move
into another country what are some of
the things
or considerations you might have so
product intuition
there's a pretty wide range of questions
that we've seen
but i would very much view this as
thinking about an
existing product and saying how could i
modify it or how could i change it for x
or how could i create a new set of
products to meet a specific set of
requirements
so product intuition is probably the
most common one i think i've seen this
in basically every interview
this one varies a bit on the company but
another core
responsibility of product managers to
have some notion of design
and product management design are
different disciplines
for sure and they're different set of
skills required to be excellent at both
but at the same time there's a fair
amount of overlap between them and
one of the reasons there's overlap is a
key tenant of
good design is deeply understanding the
customer and that is one of the skills
or the knowledge the product manager can
often bring to the table
so we've seen some design questions i
would say this one
probably exists in more than half of the
interview loops that i've seen
um and it's not designed in the sense of
do you know how to use photoshop or do
you know how to use sketch or figma's
design in the sense of
well i'm going to give you something
existing like an existing product or any
distant feature we have
and i'm going to give you a set of
constraints and a set of challenges
i want to see you actually draw what we
would build and the drawing is not the
important part we're not
like the purpose of this is not you know
are you an excellent sketcher
the purpose of this is are you able to
construct something at wireframe level
fidelity that
deeply thinks through all of the
decisions you actually have to make
to construct something that somebody
would actually use so design
very common we see this on a bunch
technical ability is interesting this
one is fairly hit or miss
in that some companies are very into
this and they want to make sure like all
of their product managers actually have
computer science degrees for example
some companies are very much in the
other end of the spectrum and do very
little technical screening for product
management at all
um so i think this one has a pretty high
range in uh
in what i've seen but i'll give you my
take on it
my take on it is that product managers
spend a lot of time working
with engineers whether it's hardware
whether it's software or whatever it
happens to be
you're going to spend a lot of time with
people whose job is to turn
drive a spec sheet into reality and if
you're not able to be credible in front
of those people
you're going to have a very difficult
time uh commanding respect and
and and make and being a real leader of
that team
so my take on this it's not about the
degree it's not about
having a check box on your resume that
says i took the certificate i did this
fast
really what it's about is if we put you
in a room with a bunch of highly
technical people
are you able to come out of that with a
credible discussion where they walk away
saying
i respect that person's ability there's
a lot of different ways to accomplish
that
it can be side projects it could be a
tinker it could be many decades of
tinkering it could be self-taught it
could be school taught
um pretty agnostic on how it's
accomplished
but my personal take on this is it's not
about having the degree per se
it's about making sure that we put you
in a room with talented people
who are responsible for converting paper
ideas into reality
you can come out of that credit
discussion incredibly every time
the second to last one i see very
commonly some notion of analytical
ability
um you might have heard of uh consulting
style questions
around estimation or fermi estimation or
some other things
um a lot of what this question is trying
to get at is your ability to think
precisely and your ability to do
estimation and
the reason estimation matters and
tobacco on blood math matters
is it's a really powerful tool for
making decisions to try and figure out
if you're on the right path
this is a combination of quantitative
thinking and
precision of thinking analytical
questions can be things like cases they
can be things like formulating written
arguments
it can be writing a one-page document
outlining a strategy this one has
a lot of variation in the forms that we
see but it's very much a core skill
around
your ability to think quantitatively not
just qualitatively and your ability to
construct
a coherent set of arguments that another
person can understand
the last topic that we see a lot is
prioritization and prioritization
is a as a whole topic that we can spend
many many hours on
a really core part of the product
manager job is prioritization and to say
of all the set of things we could do
what are the things that we're actually
going to pick and why is that the right
set of things
so there's a there's a ton of different
prioritization frameworks out there
that anybody can go look up after this
um for me it's a lot less about in
particular correct prioritization
framework i don't really think there is
a correct prioritization framework
but it's about making sure that you have
a strong toolkit of
how to do prioritization you know things
like uh how to do estimations of
impact estimations of cost the basic
math around things like return on
investment
and then making sure that you're
applying that in a consistent and
coherent way to produce something
prioritization's again very much a skill
that we see commonly
uh come up from the product management
perspective um so that was
sort of the the structured stuff that we
wanted to cover today um i wanted to
make sure that we leave a little bit of
time for
for q a so i'm going to turn it back
over to pax to take the lead on
the next topic great
thank you anon that was wonderful okay
with that i want to move into the q a
with uh anand so anon we got several
types of questions that might be
uh unsurprising so i thought we might
work through them kind of
in in blocks so the biggest block is is
is kind of similar to a lot of things
that you already
went over which is what makes a good pm
if i'm going to transition into it from
a technical background a business
analytics uh background you know what
makes a good
pm so i thought maybe it might be useful
if you talk a little bit more
just go into a little bit more detail
again if you're choosing one or two
sort of potential career paths into pm
to talk a little bit more about so if
you're a technical if you have a
technical background
what are the things you might want to be
thinking about right now if you want to
make that move into the pm and then
maybe we can choose
one other as well say you're moving from
sales into pm what might be some of the
things you want to think about and learn
about in order to make that transition
sure um i very much view the core
like product management is still down to
two sentences is what problem are you
solving and why is it important
and that is the heart of product
management in my opinion
um it's the part that the product
manager most exclusively owns so
you may work with a designer on how
should we solve that problem you may
work with an engineer on how should you
build that problem
but really the the part of the product
life cycle where you are the
core owner and that is often a send me a
solitary activity is
what problem are we solving and why is
it important so let's take the
the engineer example that you mentioned
one of the common ways that
i see those transitions be rocky is uh
when you transition from an engineering
background
you immediately jump to how should we
solve this problem and that is not
the core problem that a product manager
needs to solve the core
question of the product management
answer is what problem are we solving
why is it important
um same on the sales side of things the
the thing your brain might
naturally jump to is well how do we sell
this so a big part of the
the transition from function a to
product management is
making sure that you you you take the
set of skills that you have developed in
your prior role
you put them you sort of
compartmentalize them a bit and say
that is everything doesn't look like a
nail when i'm holding a hammer
and you make sure that you're not sort
of applying the wrong skills when
necessary
um and then when you get to that part of
the the product life cycle where it's
how should we actually solve it or how
do we actually sell it that's when you
pull out your tool kit and you say
great i know what to do with this um but
i'd say that the number one way that i
see those transitions go poorly
is overly relying on the prior set of
skills that you had that made you good
at your past job which are not the same
skills that make you good at the next
job so it's it's having this
this almost this map of the skills
that's pretty similar to what we shared
earlier on
and recognizing when you're in a place
where you sort of know how to do that
and recognize you in our place you don't
know how to do that and being
intellectually honest about it
that's fantastic okay um
kind of forward is once you are a pm
what is that career path
i mean maybe you're just building on
your own what does that career path look
like how do you evolve and grow
in that role yeah there's a lot of
different ways to do this
um uh i would say there's probably two
axes that are interesting to think about
from product management career
perspective
one of them is the notion of moving up
from a people management perspective
so if you're an individual contributor
product manager
then maybe you're a manager product
manager then a manager of managers then
maybe a head of a function that may be
an executive
there's a career path there that looks
like progressing to the people
management side of things
there's another career track that looks
like progressing through the complexity
side of things
so there are very very senior product
managers for example who don't
manage people but manage extraordinarily
large
extraordinarily complicated sets of
projects so that the two axes i would
really think about are
complexity of project or just scope of
project
an ambiguity of project and then people
management
and my suggestion to people is that they
not be too focused on the people
management side of things
it can be a thing that you want if it's
a thing you're interested in
but some of the brutal math here is um
for every
somewhere say there's one product
manager for something like every seven
engineers and there's one product
manager manager for every seven product
managers
there's a manager of managers for every
49 product manager the maths rc is
pretty complicated
you don't really get these levels of
product managers until you have
multi-hundred or multi-thousand-person
organizations so
i very much encourage people to think
not only about the people managing side
of things but also about the skills side
of things
and to figure out how you're working
through progressively larger and not
just larger but more ambiguous problems
so as a more senior product manager how
do you
help guide junior product managers
through this path
what are some of the things that what
are some of the problems you set them
what are some how do you
sort of structure this totally there's a
there's a whole um
if uh you happen to join my team or we
will sit down for an hour
uh in the first week that you start and
we're gonna walk through a whole way
about how i think about this
so the way that i think about this is
the product management job really breaks
down into two different
domains one of them is what we call a
problem space and one of them is what we
call the solution space
and for people who are curious about
this we spend a lot of time in
the online class talking about this
problem space is really what problem are
we solving and why is it important the
solution space is how should we solve
this problem
and for new product managers the problem
space is much harder than the solution
space
as sort of a general statement and for
new product managers the set of things
that i'll give them is usually
a product a project that i already know
is important so it's a pre-prioritized
a project where i already know how to do
it i already know what the answer is
and i just want them to do it there's
really an execution problem it's a
project management
and a sort of a team credibility problem
once you get good at that you go up one
level and upload level is
great same thing no problem space
ambiguity we already know what the
problem is we already know why it's
important
then you get a little bit of solution
space ambiguity so maybe
we don't know what the answer is there
might be three different ways to solve
this and we sort of want you to pick the
best one
so you expand the scope a bit up one
from that is a lot of
solution space ambiguity so we know we
want to solve this we have literally no
idea how to do it it's sort of
complicated it's thorny like you figure
out the best solution
and only after you've worked your way
all the way up the solution side of
things to go over to the problem side of
things
the problem side of things is now should
we do this in the first place
so the intro to the problem side is
great
you're sort of a basket of things and
you tell me what we should do uh and
it's about taking the basket and
building road maps
and once you get really senior on the
problem side it's not even a basket of
projects just a goal
the goal is just like hey we want to
break into this new market or we want to
launch in a new country
or we're not winning in this demographic
we want to be winning this demographic
or sometimes a revenue goal we need a
new line of things that makes 25 million
in recurring revenue like it's
very loose and very broad and your job
is to figure out
all of the things associated with the
problem side and the solution side
that's fantastic um that sounds great
that
is is and how often in reality i mean
how how
easily can you actually structure in
that way i mean in a fast-moving
fast-paced environment
do you have a lot of success in sort of
setting them up in that way
pretty well and the reason it works
pretty well is
for more senior product managers to be
capable of doing anything down that list
so the job of the senior product manager
support the junior product managers
so you don't get to say you know i opt
out of the low-level stuff just because
i'm senior
no your job is to make sure that all the
little stuff gets done so it's very much
a leading from the front mentality
so if you have an imbalance where maybe
there's too many solution things not
enough problem things
great senior product managers going to
take over and they're going to pitch in
and they're going to do the stuff they
did when they started earlier in their
career
because what needs to happen so it's
about being outcome oriented for the
organization it's not about saying
no i'm two seniors do this type of work
that's great um so kind of moving from
you know how to break in to the career
path to maybe
a few questions that came in about
defining the role further so
one of the big ones that came up a few
times and you've already touched on this
but
but if you can elaborate on the
difference between a product manager and
a project manager and they're obviously
quite different but i think there's a
lot of confusion
totally um so let me start with what i
think that the role of a project manager
is
a project manager's job is to keep the
trains running on time we already know
what problem we're solving we already
know why it's important
we already know how we want to solve it
my job is to do all the messy things
around making the execution run on time
and project management is an
increasingly important role
as you have uh more complicated projects
or projects that require large numbers
of disciplines
so if you're working on you know if
you're working on a rocket for example
project management is very much like a
core skill
and is sometimes broken out into
literally different roles where that's
the only thing that they do
that is a subset of the job of a product
manager the the real job of a product
manager is
should we do this thing in the first
place not how do i keep the trains
running on time
and once you get to the point where you
figured out that we should do it you
will have a project management component
to make sure that it actually gets done
um i mentioned that
i mentioned in uh in the webinar that
you know you can have the best laid
plans in the world if you don't actually
get stuff done it doesn't matter
um so a good product manager needs to
have project management skills
but so the hard part of the role is
should we even do this in the first
place and how should it work
not how do i keep the execution
management
that's awesome um the other thing that
came up a lot and uh i think a lot of
people
really loved your phrase influence
without authority so
can you elaborate on sort of two sides
of that just in general can you talk a
little bit
more about some tips on how to do that i
know you've talked about this in the
past
and maybe more specifically the pm role
seems to
move across a lot i mean part of a
function is move across a lot of aspects
of the organization so how do you
while influencing without authority how
do you avoid stepping on the toes of say
sales or something like that
yeah um so let me talk about the maybe
the second one first
um maybe this is naive but sort of a
hallmark in my
from my perspective of well-run
organizations is you shouldn't be
worrying too much about toe-stepping um
and there's almost always enough work to
be done and enough challenges to be done
and um if people aren't welcoming the
help maybe there's something done back
there from a company culture perspective
so i don't tend to spend a lot of time
worrying about the toe stepping piece
but at the same time it's being like
it's being humble and recognizing that
if the sales team has talked to 10 000
customers and you've talked to five
what's the chance you just walk into the
room and have the best ideas probably
not that high
um so that's the second piece the first
piece to influence the authority what is
some strategy string as well
um i'll give you a couple um this
basically comes down to how do you form
very strong and coherent arguments and i
think there are two
real sets of skills that product
managers need to build here
one of them is a combination of anal and
analytical and written and the other one
is oratory the oratory ones are if you
are not a persuasive speaker
you're going to have a very difficult
time influencing without authority
a lot of tools and tricks that are
independent of product management for
becoming good at that
you need to be good at public speaking
you need to be good at creating coherent
arguments on the fly
you need to be good at a lot of things
that look like
speaking to large groups of people you
need to learn sort of the patterns and
the narratives for giving presentations
that is a set of skills you can practice
that is independent of product
management that looks mostly like
combination of public speaking
especially extemporaneous public
speaking
the second one is really constructing
strong arguments and constructing strong
arguments i think has
a thought piece and a writing piece a
product manager a good product manager
will probably spend a third of their
time reading a third of their time
writing a third of their time talking
and we talked we spoke about the talking
piece the reading and the writing is
reading gives you information to
formulate really strong arguments and
then you must write them down
you must write them down in a way that
is extraordinarily clear and
extraordinarily precise
which provides a brief for anybody to
walk through the argument and say
i understand why we're doing this i
understand why it's important and this
is an airtight argument
so the skills i would really think of
are
reading and digesting large amounts of
information and then forming conclusions
from them that are
that are not uh super biased so like
you're trying to go where the data takes
you
the second is writing it down in a clear
and concise way for anybody to consume
the third is being able to
extemporaneously speak to large sets of
people about
the prior two things those are the core
set of skills for influencing without
authority
great thank you anan i think we have
time for maybe two more quick questions
so
the first one is uh
how or have you seen the role of product
manager changing
both just recently in general but more
specifically in response to covert 19.
yeah i'll talk about the more general
one first uh ten years ago nobody wanted
to be a product manager so like when i
broke into the field
uh it just like wasn't a thing that came
up um
a lot of people were like what is that
i've never heard of it and now we see
people coming out of business school
or just lots of different areas where
there's a lot of interest and excitement
i think it's a it's it's grown in
interest sort of as technology has
become an increasingly large portion of
the sector
like the us gdp uh or the world gdp
and the reason that there are more and
more product manager roles
is one of the challenges of software is
if you can build anything you want
picking the right thing is almost the
hardest problem so i've seen just a lot
more interest a lot more excitement
about the product management field both
because i think there's more work to be
done and i think
it's a it's a way that a lot of people
are interested in breaking into the
technology sector
um on the kova 19 side of things uh this
has been a very interesting learning
experience for me
one of my very strongly held beliefs is
is difficult to be a product manager
remotely
and the reason that i think that's true
is because it's such
a large portion of your job is of
influence
without authority there's a lot of
benefit to be had
from you know the hallway conversation
the pulling somebody aside the in-person
meeting all of that stuff
and kobe 19 has very much made a lot of
those things go away
or become remote so it's pushed a lot of
previously unstructured work in the
structured work like
more written documents more structured
check-ins
more explicit you know go no-go meetings
in ways that have previously been a
little bit more informal
so i think kobit 19 in a weird way has
forced
it has forced us to think like a bigger
company so pilot's about a
130 140 person organization i say
previously my job
a big part of my role was how do we make
that act like a 75 person organization
so it can be a little bit faster and a
little bit more nimble
but that had a very heavy emphasis on
in-person communication
and now we probably act more like a 200
person organization we write things down
we have recurring meetings we have a lot
of structure
that is forced to exist as a replacement
for in-person communication
that's great so it sounds like it's a
product manager's problem to solve
very much uh i'm being a little bit
facetious here but
uh one of my core beliefs is that
being good at product management just
gives you a toolkit for problem solving
it's not about product management per se
you spend a lot of time
sitting and intentionally thinking about
building a tool kit for being good at
solving problems
you can buy that personalized you can
pilot can apply that to whatever but is
one of very few
jobs where your responsibility is to
think about how to be good at solving
problems in the abstract sense
that's fantastic uh so maybe as a last
question then before we sign off
we've talked about some of the courses
that are available for stanford you've
talked about some of the experience you
have
any other general advice for people who
are interested in breaking into where
they should go to learn how they should
learn about product management
yeah um i mean i'm obviously biased as a
teacher of a couple of courses
um if you're interested in taking those
i would strongly encourage it
in all seriousness one of the reasons we
created um
the online course originally we created
the in-person class at stanford and then
we turned it into online course
the reason we did that is we struggled
to find resources that we really liked
for our new product managers
i think there's a lot of good
information out there product management
interviews
and then it just stops it's like great
how do you get the job
now you have the job and good luck
figure it out and people are trying to
pull together
a roadmap for being good at their job
from medium posts and news articles and
ad hoc groups and just like all these
other things and
there is no like textbook for product
management so a lot of what we were
thinking about
when we built the online classes now
what's the video analog
the textbook for product management and
what are the set of things that i wish i
knew when i started on my career
and a lot of it is what we talked about
today it's really anchoring on the
product life cycle it's this
this knowledge of problem space versus
solution space it's a lot of things that
we discussed today
um and you can construct it by you know
reading hundreds of different blog posts
but we tried to put it all in one place
great well i think that's it and on
thank you so much for your time and
thank you everyone who joined us today
we had really excellent participation we
didn't get to nearly all the questions
hopefully it was useful to sort of
organize them by general category so
there will be more webinars in the
future if you're interested in on jz's
course
please check it out again there's a link
right there on your user interface
and about a week from today you will get
a recording of this webinar so you can
re-watch it if you missed any of it or
if you want to better absorb the
material so
thank you anon and thank you everyone
who joined us today
thank you everyone
you